when you talk to businesses it's like
how much have you done like 50 million
dollars that's crazy like that's not
what they're actually gonna do this year
that's like what they would do if this
best month continued for the next 12
months that's what they would do like
why do you think people I don't say like
inflate it do you think that's kind of
like what they're doing yeah I think
it's status it's always a way of bumping
their status like up one level like
rounding up it's something that I
actually work on a lot it's like try not
to round up I want to be accurate so
46.2 and then trying not to qualify
because two very rich people that is
nothing and to very poor people that is
everything I can't guess what someone's
going to see by that so it's just that's
what it is